for more information on tutoring
personalized video solutions or how to
support move university in the
production of more videos please visit
moof university com thank you and enjoy
so as far as Row 3 goes for the ground
state electron configurations we're
going to continue to apply the Aufbau
principle to get the configurations and
so what you'll notice in this videos
that I've already have them right now as
long as you have a little alpha diagram
thing you can use that to help you
figure out what the energy is of each
orbital or at least the order in which
you fill them so I have them all
completed here so if you want to pause
the video and take a look at these
ground state electron configurations you
should be able to make sense of them
okay and also there are the orbital
diagrams over here to the right okay
again you can pause the video and figure
this out as you like now one thing I'd
like to point out is that there's
something new that I mentioned in this
video and i'm going to show you
basically for the first for the first
element and maybe move the first two i
don't know so that you can kind of
figure out what's going on and then
maybe apply that as well to the other
elements so for sodium we're gonna start
off with 1s that's going to be filled
1s2 it has 11 electrons 1s2 2s2 2p6 and
then we have three s1 ok that's the
ground state electron configuration now
there's this thing called the condensed
electron configuration what is that
basically it just makes our life a
little bit easier and shorter in the
last video I mentioned that neon a noble
gas has a filled all of its orbitals all
of its atomic orbitals are filled
completely so specifically neons the
house configuration was 1s2 2s2 2p6
which is this right here so to make our
lives a little bit easier we can just do
the electron configuration of sodium and
say well it's everything up to neon and
then 3s1 and so the way we can represent
that is like this neon and then 3s one
so basically with putting me on in
it says this is basically coming from
this that's what that is okay after that
it's three s14 magnesium we would do the
same thing except it would be 3s to
following me on so that would look like
that again we're just saying that the
1s2 2s2 2p6 is implied if we just write
me on in brackets okay and we can apply
that for all of these because they all
are after me on right so we do neon up
in there and for all of these until we
get to argon the next noble gas that's
completely filled so for the the next
row we can basically just say are gone
in brackets and then whatever else from
the configuration that follows it so I
hope that makes sense and I can
encourage you to try that and try to
work through that and figure that out in
your own but again if you want any of
these particular configurations please
pause the video figure it out and check
out the orbital diagrams here i'll leave
that sort of still for a second so you
can go and pause it but i hope that
video is helpful thank you for watching
if you found that video helpful don't
forget to Like comment subscribe and
share with friends thank you and happy
studying